hola en el último vídeo dijimos que sí
tenemos una hipérbola con la ecuación x
cuadrada sobre al cuadrado menos que
cuadrada sobre b cuadrada igual a 1 la
distancia focal de dicha hipérbola sería
f igual ahí tenemos las constantes de
aquí abajo la raíz cuadrada de a
cuadrada más b cuadrada y en este vídeo
lo que quiero de mostrarte es justo esto
y de hecho lo que sabemos es que la
ecuación que tenemos por aquí es una
hipérbola y en particular habrá a la
izquierda y la derecha pues estas serían
las asín totas y esto los ejes y esto es
porque el término x es positivo y si el
término ye fuera el positivo y el x el
negativo entonces nuestra hipérbola
abriría hacia arriba y hacia abajo como
lo hice en el dibujito del extremo
derecho y la prueba que mostraremos
justo en este vídeo es simplemente un
bonche de álgebra que estaremos haciendo
idénticamente lo mismo para el caso en
cuando jesse a la positiva sólo que
cambiando las x por 10
sólo quería asegurarme que supieras esto
y ahora hay que enfocarnos en un caso en
el caso particular de la hipérbola que
tenemos justo aquí entonces esta
hipérbola que abre a la izquierda y la
derecha vamos a dibujar los ejes y
entonces ahora recordemos que cuando
teníamos o hablábamos de las asín totas
era para cuando yo era igual a más menos
b sobre a y entonces vamos a utilizar mi
herramienta de líneas para que nos
queden rectas las asín totas luego la
hiper volaba lúcida algo así la cual va
a interceptar por este lado al punto que
a cero y por este otro lado
interceptaría a nuestro punto menos algo
más pero como vimos en el vídeo previo y
luce algo así y los puntos focales van a
situarse por aquí en esta parte y
hablando en cuanto a nuestra longitud
focal que es la raíz cuadrada de la
cuadra damas b cuadrada simplemente es
esta distancia de aquí es la distancia
es la longitud focal por lo que será f
0 y menos efe
pero ahora bien lo que aprendimos en el
vídeo pasado es que la definición de la
hipérbola podemos decir que es el lugar
de todos los puntos o un conjunto de
puntos donde si tomas la diferencia de
las distancias de los focos la dicha
diferencia va a ser un número constante
por lo que este es el punto x con el
cual podría hacer cualquier punto que
satisfaga dicha ecuación cualquier punto
de la hipérbola y sabemos o más bien
digamos que si tenemos la distancia de
aquí vamos a llamarla de 1 y le restamos
otra distancia de este a este otro foco
y la que la cual llamaremos de 2 y dicho
número es una constante
independientemente de donde estemos en
ahí pero la de hecho es el lugar de
todos los puntos la hipérbola es el
lugar de todos los puntos que satisfarán
dicha condición y como aprendimos
también en el vídeo pasado la diferencia
de dicha distancia nosotros tomamos un
punto y decimos ok cuál es esta
distancia menos esta otra distancia
a la cual diremos que es igual a 2 y
entonces tenemos que de 2 menos de 1 es
igual a 2
así que ahora la primera cosa que
haremos es figurar nos que representan
d1 y d2 en cuanto a su fórmula de
distancia así que veamos que es de 1 de
1 sea la distancia entre este punto y
este otro entre el punto menos efe 0 y
lo que vamos a hacer es solamente usar
la fórmula de distancia que es como con
el teorema de pitágoras y es la
diferencia de las x sea la diferencia de
x menos
- efe que es nuestro primer punto en el
que estamos refiriéndonos esto al
cuadrado más la distancia de ye menos el
segundo punto que es 0 al cuadrado que
es cuadrada a su vez la raíz de esto
entonces eso sería de 1 y queremos que
que es de 2 entonces de dos se puede
obtener tomando el valor absoluto para
no preocuparnos acerca de esto entonces
aquí tenemos menos la raíz para hablando
en cuanto a de dos menos la raíz de x -
efe al cuadrado más que cuadrada
y ya que sería entonces igual esto bien
pues dijimos que esto sería igual a 2
que es la distancia de aquí entonces 2a
es la constante de la que estamos
hablando y veamos si podemos simplificar
todo esto y pues ahora enfoquémonos en
cómo podemos ir desarrollando esto
pasemos del lado derecho nuestra raíz
negativa y entonces de este lado
tendríamos la raíz de x menos x menos
más de más f al cuadrado más recordada y
todo esto igual a 2 a la constante ya
teníamos más la raíz
de x - efe al cuadrado más ye cuadrada y
bien ahora que tenemos estos dos
radicales de ambas partes de la ecuación
por el lado izquierdo si le damos al
cuadrado tendríamos entonces simplemente
el término de x + f al cuadrado más que
cuadrada y luego el cuadrado de aquí
tenemos que elevar el primer término que
sería 4a cuadrada es como tener un
binomio al cuadrado no entonces es sería
más 2 veces el producto del primer
término con el segundo 2 por 2 y
entonces sería 4a tenemos por aquí 4
que a su vez está multiplicando nuestro
segundo término que viene siendo la raíz
x menos 10 al cuadrado más de al
cuadrado más el segundo término elevado
al cuadrado que simplemente se
cancelaría la raíz al elevarlo entonces
tendríamos más la parte interior aún no
la voy a desarrollar entonces tendríamos
más x menos f al cuadrado
más al cuadrado y ahora vamos a ver que
podemos ir cancelando pues tenemos
bastantes términos en ambos lados de la
ecuación y vemos que por aquí tenemos
cuadrada en ambos lados
es como si restamos que cuadrada de
ambas partes sin alterarla y entonces se
cancela y luego desarrollando este
binomio al cuadrado nos queda x cuadrada
más 2 x f más f cuadrada y todo esto
igual a 4 al cuadrado más 4 a por la
raíz b aún no voy a desarrollar lo que
está dentro de la raíz para no
confundirnos entonces es x menos s al
cuadrado más de cuadrada más
desarrollando igual este binomio al
cuadrado x cuadrada menos 2x efe más y
más efe cuadrada perdón y también
podemos ir cancelando aquí términos
vemos que podemos cancelar x cuadrada
con esta de por acá también si restamos
de ambas partes f cuadrada se cancela
ahora tenemos por aquí menos 2x efe y
por acá más 2x
efe así que sumemos de x de ambos lados
de la ecuación no pasemos este término
para este otro lado así que agregando 2x
efe de ambos lados tendríamos entonces
que sumarían de este lado 4x
efe y perdón por el sonido que acaban de
escuchar voy a apagar mi teléfono y
entonces esto va a ser igual a recuerda
que solamente pase el 2x efe del lado
izquierdo entonces va a ser igual a 4 a
cuadrada + 4a
por la raíz de x - efe al cuadrado más
de cuadrada resulta un tanto fácil
perderse con tanta álgebra pero recuerde
que todo esto lo estamos haciendo para
demostrar lo que habemos planteando un
inicio entonces simplemente vamos a
tratar de ir simplificando la diferencia
de las distancias de estos dos puntos
entonces aquí la ecuación de la
hipérbola es con las as ibex y es cómo
llegar a entender por qué es dicha raíz
la longitud focal no entonces ahora
vamos a desarrollar el término que
tenemos dentro de la raíz es un binomio
al cuadrado entonces es x cuadrada menos
2 x f más f cuadrada más cuadrada y
ahora podemos dividir ambos lados de la
ecuación de entre 4 y una vez más es
para simplificar todo esto y lo
seguiremos haciendo tanto como sea
posible entonces vamos a tener de este
lado x efe - al cuadrado pues estamos
dividiendo entre 4 y de este lado sería
a por la raíz
de x cuadrada menos 2 x f más
efe cuadrada más cuadrada
y ahora podemos eliminar la raíz y para
esto le damos ambas partes al cuadrado y
entonces este se convierte en x cuadrada
efe cuadrada menos 2 veces sea también
como un binomio al cuadrado entonces
será menos dos veces a cuadrada por x
por efe mas al cuadrado
y eso es por este lado y esto va a ser
igual a elevando al cuadrado el lado
derecho sería lo mismo que tener a
cuadrada
simplemente multiplicado por lo que
tenemos dentro de la raíz ahora la
expresión que nos está quedando de todo
esto es bastante enredosa pero veamos
que podemos hacer ahora vamos a dividir
de ambos lados de la ecuación entre a
cuadrada y tendremos x cuadrada de
verdad quiero simplificar esto lo
máximamente posible y entonces tenemos
aquí esto 2 x x
efe se cancela en la cuadrada con la que
teníamos arriba al cuadrado la cuarta
entre al cuadrado nos queda simplemente
a cuadrada y esto es igual a equis
cuadrada menos 2x
efe más efe cuadrada más cuadrada y muy
bien ahora podemos cancelar si
observamos de ambos lados tenemos menos
2x efe entonces los cancelamos y ahora
esto ya no simplifica un poco más las
cosas también podemos ver que por aquí
tenemos x cuadrada y x cuadrada entonces
hay que restar la de ambos lados
para poder tener la siguiente expresión
x cuadrada por efe cuadrada sobre a
cuadrada - m x cuadrada que es la que
estamos restando íbamos a pasar
simplemente del lado izquierdo y
cuadrada entonces tus cambios signo
menos ye cuadrada y ahora vamos a pasar
este otro término espero que se entienda
cuando digo que voy a pasar tanto x
cuadrada y como ye cuadrada de mi lado
izquierdo de la expresión para es lo
mismo que si dijéramos que vamos a
restar de ambos lados de estas dos
expresiones y bueno del lado derecho
entonces nos queda simplemente efe
cuadrada y pasamos la cuadrada del lado
derecho entonces f cuadrada menos a
cuadrada ahora aquí vamos a factorizar
en esta expresión nuestra x cuadrada
entonces nos queda f cuadrada sobre a
cuadrada menos 1 todo esto multiplicado
por equis cuadradas simplemente lo
estamos actualizando luego menos ye
cuadrada igual a esta expresión que es f
cuadrada menos a cuadrada
y bien ahora podemos dividir de ambos
lados de la expresión de la ecuación
entre este término de aquí entonces al
dividir todo / efe cuadrada menos a
cuadrada tenemos
efe cuadradas sobre a cuadrada menos 1
todo esto x x cuadrada / efe cuadrada
menos al cuadrado menos ya cuadrada
sobre f cuadrada menos al cuadrado y
todo esto igual a 1 estamos dividiendo
entre sí mismo entonces pues del lado
derecho nos queda que es igual a 1 y
bueno pues una vez más si queremos
simplificar más esto multiplicamos por
un 1 al decir esto es que podemos
multiplicar el numerador por la cuadrada
y también abajo multiplicar por a
cuadrada entonces esto es igual a 1 no
no estaríamos alterando nuestra ecuación
entonces en la parte superior al
multiplicar por la cuadradas
efe cuadrada menos a cuadrada y luego la
parte del denominador esa cuadrada por
efe cuadrada menos a cuadrada
todo esto a su vez multiplicado por
nuestra x cuadrada y el segundo término
que es exactamente igual todo esto igual
a 1 y entonces estos se cancelan y creo
que ya está surgiendo esto como la
ecuación de la hipérbola por fin la luz
de este túnel de verdad nos trabamos
demasiado pero vale la pena entonces
luce de la siguiente forma nuestra
ecuación de la hipérbola sx cuadrada
sobre a cuadrada - ya cuadrada sobre f
cuadrada menos a cuadrada igual a 1 y
realmente esto ya luce como una ecuación
original o ordinal de una hipérbola que
es x cuadrada sobre al cuadrado menos de
cuadrada sobre b cuadro de igual a 1 y
dicho pues ésta sí es una ecuación de
una hipérbola simplemente cambia la
parte de nuestro denominador en el
término de y vemos que es esta distancia
de focal menos a cuadrada representa
nuestra distancia de acá arriba entonces
podríamos jugar con álgebra e igualar
dichos términos podemos decir que
esta parte de aquí es la misma de acá
simplemente vamos a igualar nuestras
constantes entonces tenemos que la
distancia focal al cuadrado menos al
cuadrado es igual a b cuadrada y ya
simplemente ahora si sumamos de ambas
partes de nuestra ecuación a cuadrada
tenemos que la distancia focal al
cuadrado es igual a la suma de las
constantes al cuadrado entonces sacando
la raíz la distancia focal es igual a la
raíz de cuadrada más b cuadrada y ahora
si comprobamos que está exactamente como
la que propusimos en un inicio de
nuestra distancia focal y optimi con
mucho optimismo es pero ahora si ya te
quede como bien claro que es la raíz de
la suma al cuadrado de dichas constantes
y eso es cuando hablamos en cuanto a la
hipérbola si habláramos de la elipse sea
la raíz de la diferencia de estas
constantes al cuadrado bueno
las constantes al cuadrado y dicha
diferencia ahora iré por un vaso de agua